is this
interview the time that you finally
announced that you're coming back to
make secret wars for marvel
i i i wish uh unfortunately
we you know we haven't had a lot of
contact with our good buddies because of
the pandemic but
um uh and they're you know and they're
busy on uh
you know making a lot of content right
now a lot of stuff so
um uh no unfortunately we don't have
that announcement for you
just thanks um okay so listen i have a
bunch of questions and some are gonna be
spoilers and those are gonna run
after uh the movie has been released um
was the film
always gonna start with the prologue in
2007.
yeah i mean that we were always playing
with the uh
you know non-linear structure to the
movie uh sort of wrap around
uh concept um and um uh you know there's
that transition built in
that moment where he realizes you know
that um
that the end is near for him and then it
it goes to the you know takes
the beginning of the story uh but you
know we were we were trying to capture
the
um the non-linear structure of the book
uh um
and um and play around with uh uh
a time and what time means to him um
and uh and you know bookend this this
epic life cycle
for this character i was going to add to
that though you know we we are
we do like to experiment at every stage
of the process writing
shooting and editing there may have been
a very brief
very brief period during the editing
process where that where the
the movie didn't open that way but we
quickly went back to it
uh i love henry jackman's theme for uh
emily and
cherry uh i'm talking can you sort of
talk about
what was your reaction hearing that
theme for the first time because it's
it's really good
yeah it's gorgeous yeah we had a very
strong reaction to it i mean
look the movie was very challenging uh
because we were trying to be so
adventurous with it because it was such
an odyssian journey
and because cherry had so many extreme
experiences
through the various chapters of the film
and we were being so stylistically
adventurous in terms of
how we were expressing the meaning of
those experiences to cherry
we felt like it was very important on a
score level
to help hold the film together and that
relationship
between cherry and emily was the key
thread of the film that was the one pure
form of human connection
that either of those characters had
throughout the movie and
even though their relationship was
complicated even though their
relationship broke down a couple times
it was that thread never went away and
it sort of stays alive through the film
and that's the essential hope of the
movie and
henry really had to deliver the the
the emote an important emotional layer
to that aspect of the movie which he
achieved he blew us away with how he
achieved it
with that score and with the way we were
able to
revisit that theme that you're talking
about
throughout the film in different ways
with different textures
and sort of that i think that's one of
the most elegant
parts of the film is how that theme
stays with you
and how it changes as the movie evolves
i'm curious about whose idea was it for
breaking the fourth wall
um in uh was that something that you
debated strongly or was it always
there from the beginning that was there
from the beginning and it was a
you know we sat with uh jessica and
angela to talk about the script
um we're trying to find ways to
translate that subjective
component from the book the narration is
critical i mean it's
a you know
you get most of his psychology and most
of his opinions which are
really interesting opinions expressed
through the narration of the book
so we were trying to find a way to
translate that
to film and it became a combination of
elements
one of which is traditional narration
another way is breaking the fourth long
addressing the audience we knew would
also benefit us because
holland is so charismatic we felt like
this would keep the audience engaged
with him as a character
even though he makes some very poor
choices throughout the course of the
film
um uh and the material is really tough i
mean this is not
you know it's not an easy watch so you
wanna again you wanna do things that
like invite the audience into
having an emotional experience rather
than an intellectual one
you know where they start pushing the
movie away because they don't want to
process it because it's
it's being presented uh in a way that um
it's hard to swallow um and then you
know the other techniques we're using
was
you know um breaking up all those
chapters
stylistically so that we you know we
could externalize cherry psychology
and make you feel what he was feeling as
subjectively as possible
meaning when he goes to boot camp
closing down the aspect ratio
using a single wide lens for the entire
sequence to heighten the absurdism that
he feels
around his training which is limited and
saturated with toxic masculinity uh and
you know i think
he's a kid with a poet's soul and social
anxiety
and he shows up at boot camp and and
as an intelligent person goes how the
hell am i going to be trained
properly to save people's life in in a
war
scenario just by being trained for a
couple of weeks
um and so we wanted you to feel that and
use the
camera techniques to help that
experience there is a really cool
uh camera shot where it's in the first
act it's when everyone's in the car
going to the bank
and you have the camera starting in the
front seat it goes to the back
it comes back to the front it's i don't
want to say it's your children of men
shot but it's your children of men shot
um and i'm just curious if you could
sort of break down that shot and where
it came from and
and sort of filming it because i know it
had to be a challenge
there's an element of this film that's
like breaking away right this is
we grew up in cleveland and there's a
bit of that sort of
working class um you know lack of
forward momentum
the mundanity of everyday life
quality to the way cherry and his
friends
uh interact and behave with one another
and we just wanted to capture that
uh real time and let you feel
like what it felt like to us you know
when we were driving in cars
to school or places with our friends
having the same conversations
they were having arguing about our
future and
uh um you know and and sort of
you know disconnecting from one another
and uh and so the cameras actually cut
into the roof of the car it's a very
small camera
and it's remote controlled if you look
closely you'll see a white van
parked in a driveway one of the
driveways that's us
with the operator
hiding as the car drove past us um
operating it
um from that vehicle i think it took
about 22 takes
and all in all about six seven hours to
get that shot correctly
uh um it was uh we were having some
technical difficulties with the length
of the shot
and the radio waves uh and we kept
losing control of the camera
so i don't think we actually got started
getting you know legitimate takes of it
until about take 14 or 15.
do you have any details you remember
from that ass
yeah i'd also mention you know tom
siegel that shot was pitched to us by
tom siegel our cinematographer
we had a very uh intense relationship
with tom siegel on this movie beca
again because the movie was being so
ambitious on a cinematic stylistic level
um that um the inner the interplay
between us and tom throughout the
process
was very exciting and he was a critical
aspect of how the movie achieved certain
things i think this shot's a perfect
example
um he's a brilliant cinematographer
and and basically he knew what we he
knew the the you know
joe and i because we work as a team you
know we we like
we like just pulling all of our other
collaborators
on the movie into our sort of team
dynamic that he and i have
and um tom was very much that kind of
filmmaker we were able to just invite
him into our process
and communicate what we're going for in
in all of these scenes uh what kind of
sort of things excite us or scare us
in terms of what we can try and then tom
comes back to us with like
ways we can actually try to achieve that
or he innovates another way
to approach it it was an amazing process
and we can go through
many examples throughout the film of
like how how tom
actually helped us uh achieve things
cinematically that we
we couldn't have done otherwise and i
think this shot is one of them were the
wrinkles around tom's eyes
at the end of the movie was that makeup
or was that cgi
now his makeup and he and his makeup
artist did an incredible job in this
film
with the two of them working together to
create this character
and to take this character on that you
know it's really an
intense very journey that he goes on um
exceptional work was it always going to
end
with the two of them outside the jail
and did you ever think about not having
them get back together at the end
no that was there from the beginning
um i mean we found it very early in the
development process of the story
uh there was a look it was critically
important to us
to get to a place where there was some
sense of hope by the end of this movie
because it was such a difficult film
such a challenging movie on an emotional
level on a psychological level
we really wanted to get to a place that
said you know what these two characters
have survived
their relationship has remained true and
they're there for one another at least
on some level
i mean one thing we love about that
ending so much is it gives you a sense
of hope
but you have no idea where those
characters are gonna go after that
moment
you don't know if they're gonna you know
sort of regress into the problems
they've had in the past
you don't know if they're going to
actually be able to coexist with one
another
but you know on some level that those
two characters even after all they've
been through
they still want to be there for one
another so
that that ending was critically
important to us
and and the ambiguity of that ending was
always very important to us
uh there may have been a brief moment
again like when we like to experiment in
the editing process
there may have been a moment where where
it was either
taken out or talked about being taken
out but the movie never really made
sense to
us without it there's a shot at the end
of the movie that i
i i love that shot where you have when
he's getting into the jail it's
going all the way to the left you know
you're dollying or whatever you want to
call it to the left
and eventually he sits down he's
listening to music and then the camera
starts going to the right and it's
always going to the right
i think till the end until he's in the
parole room
talking and it's very minimal dialogue
can you sort of talk about
how stylistically why you chose to have
the camera going like that to the left
then all the way to the right with the
minimal dialogue
it's again an instance where we're
externalizing his psychology
she says to him earlier in the film one
day it'll all stop it'll go quiet
right and you'll be okay and and it took
him going to prison
to to have that moment to find that
moment of peace
um and he has it in the yard when he's
all alone
um and he finally makes a decision to
reverse direction
reverse the course of that his life
you know that his life has been heading
in um
um for the last hour and a half of the
movie uh
and uh and that's what the camera
signifies there is that
he's made it he's made a decision uh and
um
and he's he's heading for redemption uh
what's the status of gray man
uh are you shooting soon what what's
going on with that
yeah we start shooting in about two
weeks we're in hardcore prep right now
um you know los angeles had a
a very difficult two and a half months
and
um you know we pushed the film about uh
six weeks do you know what you're going
to do
after gray man or is that up in the air
we have some ideas of what we'd like to
do but we haven't we haven't firmed
anything up yet i mean we have um
um uh uh electric state uh
um that we like to shoot uh next year
but we're just looking at dates now
where we would do that
real quick i'm out of time but i just
got to ask you whose idea was it for the
shot
looking out the [ __ ] and how much did
you debate including that shot
that was uh that shot was also pitched
to us by tom siegel
uh and it was perhaps the most debated
shot in the movie
but for that reason we kept it in
did you was it close to not being
included
no i don't think so i mean i remember
when he first pitched it we're like
that's [ __ ] nuts we're not going to
do that
uh and then he showed us
he showed us a sample of it or you know
loose the loose idea and we went
it's pretty interesting point of view
i've never seen that on camera before
uh let's do it and then um uh you know
uh
we shot it and uh it you know worked in
the cut to us
but for this very reason it's uh it's
it's it's worth keeping in the movie
there is a number of times where the
character of cherry
again the movie is so specifically from
his point of view
where he has these moments they're
almost like visions of
people that he's meeting or encountering
or experiences that he's having
uh you know that sort of are out of time
or
or sort of just fantasies of of what he
might imagine
uh their life to be outside of this
moment that he's having with them
and that's that shot sort of worked
within that context
for us which is sort of like you know
he's sort of having an
out-of-body experience of of of this
very strange thing that's happening to
him at that moment
oh okay i already got a wrap um listen
good luck with everything
and nice to see you both thanks man
we'll talk soon great to see you too